[Musique]
la municipalité d'elancourt
l'établissement public d'aménagement de
saint quentin en yvelines et le cae
conseil d'architecturé d'urbanisme et de
l'environnement des yvelines ont
présenté du 10 au 23 mars à la mairie de
la ville une exposition consacrée à la
colline de la revanche
à l'origine ce site original était une
ancienne carrière de sable et de molière
exploité jusqu'à la fin des années 70
dès lors ce lieu devient aussitôt 1,70
idéal pour les ordures et se transforme
en décharge publique
en 1972 le pea qui souhaitent aménager
ce lieu et en faire un espace boisé
décide alors d'en acquérir une grande
partie des 1976 ce site accueille les
remblais issus principalement des
chantiers de construction de la ville
nouvelle la colline prend alors forme et
devient le point culminant de la région
parisienne
d'une hauteur de 60 mètres son sommet se
situe aujourd'hui à 230 mètres au dessus
du niveau de la mer
en 1992 la colline de la revanche fait
l'objet d'un concours national d'idées
auprès de jeunes architectes et
paysagistes désormais ce site est prêt à
accueillir un projet ce que nous
souhaitons aujourd'hui c'est trouver un
promoteur qui nous ont un projet nous
n'avons pas nous collectivités locales
la capacité financière ni de mettre en
place un tel projet ni de le gérer à
long terme je crois que je n'ai pas le
droit pour un projet de ce genre de
faire prendre des risques à la budget
communal en revanche ce que nous
souhaitons c'est que healy
un projet qui ne soient respectueux de
l'environnement cet environnement doit
rester un environnement disons naturel
d'aspect naturel vers et respecte
également l'accès des élans courtois
leurs collègues sur trois scénarios
proposés le conseil municipal
d'elancourt a d'ores et déjà retenu
celui dont les options d'activités de
plein air et de glisse valorise
l'originalité de ce site
ce scénario préconise par exemple
développement d'activités liées au
relief comme l' escalade ou le parapente
la création éventuelle d'un restaurant
panoramique ou encore un lieu de loisir
urbain
si pour l'heure les choix définitifs ne
sont pas arrêtés les gens de la colline
association d'amoureux de nature et de
parapente se préoccupe de très près de
l'avenir de ce site exceptionnel vient
de la colline ce sont des locaux et des
gens un peu moloko comme moi donc
s'occupe de la colline parce qu'on y
vient assez souvent mais qui s'occupe de
cette colline pour tous les pratiquants
et pour tous les pratiquants qui
viennent
volet aujourd'hui sur la colline mais
surtout pour tous les pratiquants qui
viendront voler le jour où la colline
sera aménagé pour la pratique du
parapente
entre autres il faut savoir que
aujourd'hui à beaucoup de pratiquants
qui viennent pas parce qu'il ya encore
des bouts de ferraille qui traîne parce
que c'est pas très bien aménagé a pas du
tout de gaz ont si souvent brûlés le
jour où le site sera réaménagé on a de
fortes chances de réaliser en région
parisienne un despote du parapente
un appel d'offres devrait être lancé en
direction des investisseurs privés dès
le mois d'avril dans la tente de futurs
aménagements la colline de la revanche
lieu unique en ile de france constitue
d'ores et déjà sur terre ou dans les
airs un lieu de promenade originale
[Musique]
il